I'm Mexican we're the best two rows but
you have to do someone Molineux all
right I don't know I think I'm mad I I
don't remember having truism what the
mother I'm trying to lose some way right
now I was kind of worried about coming
here right now what I know about you
other than I'm Mexican so I know it's
your rules I think a lot
I'm hoping it's like a tiny churro
shaped over yo cuz anything else and
quite frankly I'm gonna be disappointed
no see I buy two from the street vendors
like in my head I've decided that size
matters with churros so and those are
the facts thanks I got you don't know
you got yourself I gotta go yeah yeah
I'm so smoking hot oh they look so this
no really good I like this like powder I
guess I think the powder just gotta know
he consulted but that uh yeah it's a
nice touch
I've learned myself but too drunk to
feel right now so I'm pretty sure I just
got burned boys feeling okay Oh firm
firm and nice I like it but it doesn't
affect anything like a doesn't taste
like Oreos and it doesn't taste like
children's not at all all right I get it
I mean this is a good definitely a good
drunk snap so the cream doesn't have
that like distinctive Oreo cream flavor
like it feels like cream if I was at a
store they saw these churros I would
probably get them just just in case like
I'm drunk like right now yeah I was like
I get home and I take a look at these
and I'm like how's it going guys would
it be weird if I dunk this and so they
always take religious if you did it
I bet this will give you the runs and
you don't want that like you don't you
know truce you only get them from lesson
Yoda you don't get him from anywhere
else support your local street vendors
support local street vendors for real
that's with anything universal on your
massive annuals
no it's good the little props everybody
goes bowling
that was a crime knock it again like
this that's good I would personally
recommend them I'm gonna leave I also
recommend I know I would I would eat all
to you I would eat oh yeah there are
three